>>Steve: My name is Steve Mattice,
I'm a math and science teacher here
at Roosevelt Middle School.
I have been teaching for
about seven years now.
>>Narrator: Steve had a problem.
His classroom was too
small for the 36 students
who poured in and out every period.
And too cramped to accommodate the
student-to-student collaboration he
knew encouraged deeper learning.
>>Steve: They're extending
this knowledge
when they're working together,
they're happier and more positive
and more likely to participate.
I've got a lot of kids
and a lot of desks.
Things pile up very quickly, kids
can sort of pile up quickly in here.
And the maneuverability of this
room is not always fantastic.
>>Narrator: Then he met the folks
at the "Third Teacher Plus,"
whose job it is to help educators
re-imagine their learning spaces.
See how they all took
on the challenge
of remaking Steve's classroom to be
a home for exploration, creativity
and better communication.
>>Christian: Teachers around the
country will totally identify
with this classroom, an incredible
number of kids and limited space.
So one of the things
we're going to be looking
at is how does Steve move
around the classroom.
>>I'm Christian Long, and I was
a high school English teacher
for about 15 years.
As a member of the "Third Teacher
Plus," our job is to create spaces
that allow the people
to be remarkable students,
remarkable educators.
>>Melanie: When people
think design a lot of times,
they think veneer,
they think decorating.
Yeah, we want it to look
better, but unless we can change
and facilitate a really
productive classroom,
then we're not really
making a difference.
>>I'm Melanie Kale, and I'm a
Design and Learning Strategist
at the "Third Teacher Plus."
We're going into a classroom
identifying things that work,
and things that could work better.
Taking a thousand dollars,
a designer's eye,
a lot of community resources.
We try to match the physical
classroom environment
to teaching and learning goals.
In one weekend, we
hopefully realize them.
>>Christian: So, Steven, tell us
a little about this classroom,
how it works, how it's laid out.
>>Steve: There's very little room
to sort of move through the middle,
so I kind of stay on the outskirts
when I do have to move around.
I've got 36 kids, plus
backpacks, books, jackets.
There's so much stuff
just within the aisles.
Just trying to get through is almost
like trying to get through rush hour.
>>Melanie: In your world here, what
is crucial that you have up here
to be successful in class?
>>Steve: I use the ELMO
or the overhead a lot.
Just for more direct teaching.
The ELMO is a document camera
that connects to a projector
and projects anything that I'm
writing up onto the screen.
It's not a big workspace.
Like obviously, I've got a
stool here to sort of make-do.
I do "McGuiver" this stuff.
>>Christian: What we're hoping
to do here with Steven's class is
to really support this
idea of collaboration.
He's got to focus on teams, so
you see these groupings of four.
But at the same time,
there's very little room
from grouping to grouping.
>>Melanie: So the workshop
we ran on Monday,
the goal is to get a
pulse on the students.
See how they collaborate
with one another,
see how they interact
with other adults.
A lot of times words don't
encapsulate what we're thinking.
So we created a gallery wall for
them to facilitate visual listening.
The visual listening wall
has hundreds of photos.
It can be any size, and we
give them dots to vote with.
It allows us to quickly take the
pulse of what their eye is drawn to,
place they want to learn in, a
place they want to hang out in,
a place that just looks cool.
>>Let's hear about it.
>>Student: We'd be like
learning from each other,
or as like not just learning based
on one thing like from a book.
>>Melanie: And what we noticed
with them is they like sitting
in their groups of four,
but they want to feel
like they're a part of a whole.
So in this class, we're
considering the perimeter,
we're considering how we
can add more mobility.
While we might not have a plan right
this moment, we know our priorities.
To help make teachers better
designers, we ask teachers
to invite critical
friends into their room.
That might mean another teacher in
the same department, another teacher
in a different department,
or their architect friend
from down the street.
We do this thing called
a solution session
to create really concrete areas that
we can prioritize and make happen.
This session is really
about putting some specifics
on what we think can really make a
difference for your everyday life.
And on Monday morning, you have
to have a classroom to teach in.
We set up a big board.
It kind of becomes our shared brain.
It's a place where we can visualize
all the things that we're thinking.
We identified a handful of key areas
that we were going to focus on:
Display; Storage; Furniture;
Teaching Zone; Personality.
And we picked those spatial areas
so that we can create
concrete solutions around them.
We asked Steven to
help us identify things
that he thinks are going
to make a big impact.
>>Student: First things that kind
of caught my eye were the
teacher desk as a DJ Dashboard.
The positioning of the desks,
I think, could be re-imagined.
Pull the doors off the cabinets.
Activate the back wall.
The things that the
designers are going to do
in this class have
sort of opened my eyes.
The insights that they've
shared have made me think
about things I wouldn't
ever have thought about.